difficile de tenir les enfants
aujourd'hui pour la sortie du premier
épisode d'harry potter dans le monde
entier le film est en train de battre
tous les records d'entrées de l'histoire
du cinéma en france les quatre tomes
déjà parus se sont déjà arrachés à plus
de 7 millions d'exemplaires un succès
inédit pour un conte qui a su séduire
toute une génération
un film très attendu mais qui doit
désormais résister aux critiques très
sévères d'un public qui a lu et relu
toutes les aventures du petit sorcier
payen blary disent ils n'ont pas eu le
même caractère des fois par mgi disent
que ses cheveux ils sont bouclés dans le
premier dans le livre est donc là ils
ont les cheveux te prennent ici c'était
ben harper d'une recette magique qui
fait forcément des émules et aujourd'hui
on ne compte plus les livres de sorcier
ou de sorcières en herbe un univers
magique et effrayant qui comme le prouve
le succès d' halloween fait mouche
auprès des enfants